problem session and this is Ken Clarkson
visiting us from IBM research aladen
thanks thanks for uh the invitation to
speak um this is Joint work with
shashanka ubaru also at IBM and
Elizabeth Yang who did this as a summer
intern at IBM uh while she was a student
here here at Berkeley and she's now at
open AI so I I have the bad habit of uh
starting out talks with apologies and I
I'm still going to indulge that bad
habit in that I just so there's not much
algorithm design here it's all analysis
um it's things that you you actually
already know a lot about um uh in dis in
a little bit of
Disguise um and so I just I just want to
set expectations appropriately low but
uh now having done that I will uh I will
then tell you first of all what what
this is about so there's at least
there's a a a small group of people who
work on something called Vector symbolic
architectures or uh now now also called
hyperdimensional Computing um it's not a
it's not a big group in terms of the
people terms of you know machine
learning and so on but it's still
relatively large maybe compared to the
the theory Community well maybe smaller
than the theory Community but comparable
I would say um and and what these are
about uh if you boil it down in the
terms that as as we would talk about
them
is that there are ways of just
representing discrete sets using a
single Vector um and on which that
single Vector you can do membership
testing and then there's a bunch of uh
operations that you can do on on that
vector or on two vectors so bundling
binding and permuting and first of all
you can represent a discret set with a
characteristic Vector of that set so
this is not you know Innovative in that
sense um but uh it it you know this
particular representation has some
advantages and has a a simple direct
relationship with characteristic vectors
as as I'll as I'll talk about in in the
next uh slide or two so so the setting
here is that we have um a set of
discrete elements and let's say they're
just the integers from one to D just you
know number the elements and that's
that's what we regard as the ground set
and we're going to be looking at uh
trying to manipulate subsets of that
ground set and then we have uh for some
Dimension M we have the the Atomic
vectors of the of the vector symbolic
architecture the vssa for one particular
uh flavor or of of uh Vector symbolic
architecture called map I the atomic
vectors are sign vectors uniform random
plus plus one minus one vectors um and
and we have then um D of them so we have
you know D sign vectors in in M
dimensions and and starting with those S
vectors we can do these operation on
them which are in the case of mapi
bundling which is just adding them uh
binding them which is doing element wise
multiplication of them and a permutation
or rotation of them and I'll basically
just talk about one flavor of this which
is um just kind of rotating you know so
that the first element becomes the
second the second becomes the third and
then the last becomes the the first um
unless it's in the other direction in
the way that I defin the rotation Matrix
in this case but in any case it's a you
know one version of of this kind of
operation would be to just multiply by a
matrix such that you're doing kind of a
a permutation of the coordinates of the
of of whatever Vector you're you're
operating on so so there are these these
operations um which there's for for
different vsas there's different kind of
atomic vectors different versions of
bundling binding and
permutation um or or in some cases you
know it doesn't quite make sense to have
binding operations let's say so so we a
subset of these
operations and and they these these
operations have uh you know kind of very
simple properties that as as you might
expect but one thing that's that's
needed in these is a is a sort of a
similarity a notion of similarity for
for two vectors which in our case would
just be if their dotproduct is is large
enough and I'll leave what large enough
means uh to be defined um later so as it
happens you know as you well know two s
vectors in sufficiently large Dimension
have will be approximately orthogonal to
each other with high probability or just
it's sufficient for for now to just say
that they're with high probability
unlikely to be similar to each other so
or with sorry with high probability they
will be dissimilar to each other so um
we we have this kind of blessing of
dimensionality in the sense that we have
these high-dimensional vectors that are
pairwise um nearly orthogonal to each
other so the the kinds of conditions
that we that that we want to have for
these vssa um algebras are you know
commutativity and associativity of of
the bundling and binding operators um or
that that was certainly true in the case
of mapi in the case of the particular
scheme that I that I just described um
The Binding distributes over bundling um
two vectors X and Y are similar to the
bundle of X and Y you know that the
dotproduct of X with X Plus Y is is
large enough for for our purposes um n
none of the vectors that we consider
will will be typically uh similar to The
Binding of two vectors and there's a uh
an operation that in general is
unbinding but in the case of mapi is
simply you know just multiplying just
binding with one of the vectors again so
that you can sort of trivially recover
um each each of the two vectors in The
Binding by binding again with one of
those vectors so you bind again with X
and you get y you bind again with Y you
get X so so these these simple
operations then allow you to you know
basically Implement various data
structures um very simple data structure
so so sets which are subsets of of the
integers from one to D where you just
bundle them by taking the uh the bundle
over all of the members of of the set um
of the you take the bundle over all of
those of their corresponding Atomic
vectors so for each each member of the
set there's a there's an atomic Vector
um you can do insertion by bundling with
the appropriate Atomic vector and you do
membership test using this similarity
operation you could also have a a set of
of unordered sets let's say just a set
of unordered pairs you know so in
general uh bracket D choose n but let's
say n is equal to two and in that case
you could represent it as a bundle of
bindings and then recover um for for n
equals 2 you would recover uh you know
one element of that of that of of one of
those bindings by binding with the other
one so you so SI times this
representation of that whole bundle of
bindings
ultimately uh comes down to uh s j for I
and J in in this in this set ultimately
comes down to SJ plus a number a
collection of of bundles and bindings
and so on that if you are looking for
that that constitute sort of noise when
when you then take the dotproduct with
SJ to check that SJ is similar to to
this uh to this expression so this is I
mean this is a a lot to read maybe but
it's just Distributing the the um The
Binding over the bundling and then
applying this this fact about this
simple fact about the the bind a binding
twice amounts to multiplying by the
identity and finally you could you can
represent an ordered list of of of
entries by doing a bundle of rotations
of each one of the corresponding uh
Atomic vectors um and then Rec be able
to check membership in the list at a
given position by doing a kind of an un
rotation and then checking that you have
similarity at that point
so what's the point of all this um um so
it is a way to do um to to have a you
know particularly with the bundle of
bindings to do a kind of distributed
associative memory it's unlike
characteristic vectors let's say it's
robust to errors um it's a minimal they
tell me to inmemory
computation some versions of it are
related to um
mod vectors you know computations that
that that seem to arise in um uh you
know in in in some some models of neural
networks um and and I would say actually
so there's the Redwood Institute here on
the Berkeley campus um is is kind of the
ground zero so to speak of of this kind
of work and and their interest in it
comes I think from the sort of
biological inspiration Etc also as I'll
as I'll mention it's related to um
hopfield networks classical hopfield
networks as as I'll described and and
actually you know doing this kind of
thing also comes up in spread Spectrum
Wireless um so are there any or any
questions or comments at uh at this
point just to see
anybody okay once
um so so a way to to look at this which
um actually you were probably already uh
you know assuming or guessing is is well
that suppose you take these D Atomic
vectors M dimensional Atomic vectors and
you arrange them as Columns of a matrix
so they're s vectors and so now you have
a signed Matrix and if you were to
multiply that that uh that Matrix
suitably scaled by the characteristic
Vector of a given set that is to say the
Char so you're just picking out the
appropriate columns and adding them up
then in in the map ey algebra what you
end up with is the is you know the
bundle that represents that set so so
the the vssa representation of a set is
just the sketch of its characteristic
Vector uh you know the characteristic
Vector of that
set so so vssa is just kind of sketching
in in very very light
disguise um so I also we we'll need to
kind of introduce an SAR which is this
appropriately scaled version of of S
because sometimes it's it's nice to be
able to to to uh have things
appropriately scaled in terms of various
statements You' want to make um and when
D is much larger than M when the size of
the ground set is is very large then
this is a kind of compression it's a
it's a way of compressing the
characteristic Vector um in in D
dimensions
down to to M dimensions and then be able
to do oper setwise operations that are
um uh kind of uniformly done on all of
the elements of the all of the entries
of the resulting vector and and for
which it's it's also possible to kind of
recover from local errors and so on so
that this is a robust representation in
that sense that if you change one entry
of a vector it's still you know it's
still going to be similar to the things
that it was similar to before so so it's
it's robust to error to to local errors
in that
sense um so that that membership test
then then translates into to you know
it's a DOT product and now I put in the
scaling so that the upshot of this is
just looking at the the you know using
sketching to estimate the The Matrix
Vector product of the I natural basis
vector and the and the characteristic
vector v so you're just doing
approximate uh vector vector product you
know uh approximate matrix
multiplication by way of sketching so so
this is you know you you I'm
I I'm sorry to bore you but but it is it
is uh at least of some interest to
Simply Be able to say that the um that
this you know this this scheme is can
can be uh directly analyzed and some
some aspects of it just just you know
it's it's analysis just read off from
from standard things in in uh in in the
theory of
sketching so so kind of more more
generally than membership test we could
also look at um the looking at
estimating the size of the intersection
of two sets or the symmetric difference
of two sets and that naturally
translates into a sketching based
estimate of the dotproduct the
characteristic vectors of the two sets
or the uh sketching based estimate of
the ukian norm of the two sets Okay and
the the basic question of analysis here
is what is the what is a dimension
sufficiently large so that you can do
these membership tests and do these uh
set intersection queries uh with reason
with given you know with guaranteed
accuracy um with high
probability um and and and and our work
is is basically a a follow-up to work by
um Thomas dasgupta and Rosen um who
looked at set membership and who um used
used similar you know the incoherence
terminology and so on that we that has
also been you know a way of talking
about sketching and JL and so on um and
the the contribution here is to kind of
extend their work in particular extended
to to set intersection and so on and and
try to be as comprehensive as we could
about uh the analysis of of different
different
vsas all right and I will there's
there's a there's a lot of text here but
this is this is things that you're
probably all very familiar with first of
all that that the reason why this works
is is kind of generalizations of JL you
know so we're Johnson lindra ran a
projection so we have this we can we
have uh estimates for how big how much
error there's going to be in using this
sketching based estimate of the dot
product where it comes up with an
additive error that's it's Epsilon times
the norm of one characteristic Vector
times the norm of the other
characteristic vector and that
translates to um an expressions in terms
of the cardinalities of the sets so a a
characteristic of this of the of these
vsas is that they can have ground sets
which are extremely large but
nonetheless the the actual sketching
Dimension necessary is going to be uh
dependent on the uh the the the
cardinalities of the sets that are being
manipulated and and as as most of you
probably know already the a kind of
starting point for the analysis of of JL
is to show that it it preserves the norm
of a of a single Vector so the if you
know you suppose you have some sketching
distribution so that the squared Norm of
P * Y is equal to 1 plus or minus
Epsilon time the squar norm of Y so say
that that that satisfies single Vector
Norm preservation then from it you know
using a union bound you get you get uh
uh preservation of norms of of many
vectors uh preservation of norms of
differences of vectors as as jl's
traditionally expressed uh preservation
of dot products of vectors using a
little bit of uh high school algebra and
so on
and as you all know probably mostly that
that you know there's nothing
particularly special here about the the
sign matrices that um you know
independent subgaussian entries are also
sufficient to have similar bounds for
this Norm preservation at least let's
not worrying about the binding and uh
and so on for now um You could also use
uh sparse JL um as as galani and Daniel
Cain uh described for for the particular
case of of of of of binding and of
bundling and also can could you one can
also use um uh subsampled randomized
hadamar transform so so various either
more sparse or uh with fewer bits uh
schemes can be used instead of IID you
know sign matrices so um so this this
already is something that the particular
VSA Community was not was not I think uh
cognizant of um okay and and I and I
have to say that that the you know in
this analysis of of bundling that I'm
it's really kind of a special case
because well if you take the union of
two sets um then you know something
that's in the intersection should only
be represented once and if you add two
characteristic vectors then things that
are in in the intersection kind of are
doubled up and
so you know if you if you were in an
online setting in which you were
bundling and Bund bundling and bundling
different different uh Atomic vectors or
different vectors representing different
sets then you know if you if you repeat
yourself if you you have an element
represented more than one time so that
you're really representing a multiset
then you know this kind of analysis
doesn't you know doesn't quite tell you
what you what you want it to tell you um
so this is just kind of in the offline
setting but but still it you know the
results also do apply for these
arbitrary sequence es of bundles um for
the for the purpose of membership
testing because you just want that to be
you just want the dot product to be
large enough you don't care how much
larger it is um so things are a little
more interesting when we look at uh
bundles of bindings and in this case the
one way to express the situation is that
you uh take the the original sign Matrix
and for every pair of columns make a new
column which is the The Binding of those
two columns that is is the element wise
product of those two columns and that
constitutes a a new uh a new column so
you have um for you know for for n
equals 2 or k equals 2 as I use using
here for sets for little or unordered
sets of size two you you would then have
D choose two columns um which if it if
it helps anybody um this is a kind of a
you take the katri r the the the rowwise
katri rout product and and then
eliminate uh identical uh uh columns and
and this is this is what you get so so
now you have a a much bigger Matrix that
is uh does not have um IID columns um
although rows continue to be uh uh IID
independent of each other um and and one
of our results is just that if you if
you do the if you look at sort of the
norm preservation question for this for
this uh Matrix that you blown up to this
extent then you you you know with
subject to you know some some log
factors you continue to have this Norm
preservation property which means that
all of the other properties you know all
of the other operations that you want to
do in terms of set intersection and set
difference and so on that that those
continue to apply in this
case so so the the analysis here be is
at least not just reading off what was
already in the prior literature it's um
uh uh uh you know it's it's a little bit
harder because we don't have
independence of of the columns but you
know we we use it's not that not
particularly difficult that we can
simply use um you know McD's inequality
in in places that we might otherwise use
Bernstein let's say um so it's it's not
too painful an analysis to do this that
you one could also view this as just a
another kind of result in which you know
I guess the the um an initial version of
this would be to just look at kwise
Independence for a very small amount of
additional Randomness this is this is
reducing the amount of Randomness for
you know in in one particular way to and
and showing that even with that reduced
Randomness um you still have you know
you still have the appropriate sketching
properties so um you know so bundles of
bindings can can be analyzed in this
fashion um rotations can also be
analyzed and and here again we we we can
think of it as constructing a a very
large uh uh sketching matrix by taking
successive rotations you know so we
start out with some sketching Matrix S
Bar rotate it take the squared rotation
and so on up to up to some number of
rotations and then and then for a given
sequence we of of characteristic vectors
we put them all together and now we can
code that sequence of sets as a as a
sketch of that very large kind of
characteristic
Factor okay so so putting things things
in in those terms we again can can put
it in terms of uh single Vector uh
proxim you know single ve Norm
preservation for for single vectors with
all of the other properties that then
that then follow um for uh again with a
with a probably not the best possible L
squared here where we're where we're
encoding a sequ a sequence of length L
um or if we have if we have a particular
condition in terms of the the number of
times that a given element occurs
anywhere in in one of these sets we can
and that that's bounded by some value k
then we have a bound that's in that's
that's with respect to this uh to to in
terms of K so so again this is uh a
little bit of a tweak on on the usual
analysis because because of this lack of
Independence that we have in these uh in
in these
matrices okay so so that was one kind of
uh vssa and I will kind of describe a
what is actually a a novel sort of sort
of VSA that's in terms of um uh what's
called a classical hot field Network so
there's classical hot field networks and
modern hot field networks and the
classical hot field Network which I'm
which I'm discussing here basically to
put it in terms that that that that that
I that you know I can understand or that
seem to be simpler than than what was
described you know back when which is
that if you um the result of training
such a network is is a is the grammian
of a of a sign Matrix so it's s x s
transpose where where s is a sign Matrix
or at any rate this that's the kind of
Matrix uh for which the the capacity
analyses of hot field networks was was
done um back when in in in in ancient
times so I'm um one thing we have here
is simply a an analysis in a in a fairly
direct terms you know simp you know
quote unquote simple terms of of
something that was done a while ago it
does feed into later things but it it's
a little bit of um because it's their
kind of kind of analysis but um the
while while hot field networks are
usually discussed in terms of iterative
processes in which there's an energy
functional and you're and you're moving
toward local Minima of the energy
functional you can also just look at it
in terms of of Matrix operations in
which you you say well suppose you you
have some Vector Y which is a s Vector
except that some some entries are zero
and and it's the case that a the sort of
normalized dotproduct of that Vector y
with one of The Columns of of this sign
Matrix is uh is is big enough then then
if you if you um take the product of ss
transpose and then but subtract off kind
of some nuisance uh diagonal terms take
the product of ss transposed with Y and
then take the the sign of that uh as
appropriately defined then with uh with
high probability you will will will
recover um uh you know that that column
s
SJ so um in in terms of the way hot
field networks are usually discussed
this is this is one iteration of a
process that then continues but but in
but in fact you can you can get a simple
guarantee of this sort after sort of one
iteration of the process so this is this
is not um the most interesting version
of of uh hopfield uh Network recovery uh
results in the sense that um it's it's
considered more interesting by people in
the field to remove a log factor and
have more errors so the you get a bigger
capacity um but in in terms of the
number of number of different column
vectors you can have but um but uh you
know allow some errors in in the actual
Rec covered result so so this is a the
the fact that you have zeros in here
means that you that would be a kind of
eraser of those coordinates and and also
you know if you have an error in which
you take a minus one and make it plus
one or vice versa then that's going to
reduce that dot product um but but
erasers are less harmful because the
erasers also reduce the norm of Y so so
they have less effect on you know you
can have more erasers and still keep
that normalized OD product sufficiently
high so this um you know the so so this
has a um uh actually has a relation to
map ey in the sense that if you split
one of the split the column vectors up
into two equal siiz pieces and look at
the the gramian that you get then
there's a diagonal of that gramian which
will be the a bundle of bindings uh of
those of those two different pieces
considered across the the the different
columns so there's a kind of a direct
relationship between uh between hot
field networks of this sort and and and
the map ey
vsas okay so so just as a matter of
notation um there's you know you could
have a you translate a given Vector to
the diagonal version of that vector by
filling in the diagonal entries with the
entries of the vector um and then here's
an actual new algorithm um which we're
calling hot field uh plus or minus um a
little bit an emulation of all those
things called plus plus this is plus or
minus and and uh I I would yeah you you
could also call it hot field you know PM
if you were using kind of latch notation
so it's sort of evening hopfield if you
like
but but uh uh sorry but uh the the thing
is that that
where does where does where does the
plus or minus come from it comes from a
a s Vector that you you diagonalize and
then if you take a characteristic vector
and diagonalize that and then look at
you know so you're sort of inserting a
given a given
Vector uh time you know element wise
product with a with a sign Vector in
between the the you know the SAR and the
SAR transpose that you would use to get
the gramian and if you do that then you
have this Norm preservation property as
with these uh these other cases um with
with these prior things and and the the
my the somewhat interesting thing about
this is that the dependence on M is such
that um you can use an an M bym uh hot
field plus or minus Network to represent
a set to represent a bundle um U uh
represent as a bundle in in in sense a a
set which is um of of uh uh you know
what you would need for a a VSA Vector
of Dimension M squared so so the the
capacity of a hot field network with
this with the addition of this plus or
minus business for the purpose of
representing a set is is actually no
less efficient than um than other VSA
representations so so there's there's
two different this is using a hot field
Network for something that it is not
commonly commonly uh used for which is
which is representing sets as bundles in
this way but the thing is that with a
little bit of tweaking with this plus or
minus we get we get something which is
uh which is which is relatively
efficient for for the
purpose okay so so that well now I have
not too much time but that concludes the
the the um the different vsas or vssa
adjacent uh operations that for which
this business about the norm
preservation implying all the other
things um is is is useful because
because from here on things are are more
nonlinear so it looks more less like
sketching and more like you know sort of
data structures or or Boolean function
analysis so in in map B um the the the
uh vectors that are manipul Cal at are
sort of more compactly expressed because
we we take the sign of of of of the sum
of the of the vectors to make a
bundle so so and and the sign here is of
a particular form so that you know it's
if if if the given value is greater than
zero then it's one less than zero it's
minus one and we flip flip a coin if
it's if it's actually equal to zero so
that that enforces um in a in an
unbiased way that we always have plus
ones and Min ones okay so so there what
we have shown is is how how big a a
sketching Dimension is needed in order
for this kind of uh operation in order
to you know so our our our offline
bundling is to take the that exact same
sign Matrix multiplied by the
characteristic vector and then take the
sign of that and and the upshot is that
there's you know that that there is an
an an a sketching Dimension m m a a an
atomic Vector Dimension M um which is
which is uh n if we want to represent n
entry such that we can do um at least a
membership in map B um with this
particular test that the this is the
similarity test which is the dot product
has to be you know that big um and we
also have results for rotations and
bundles of bindings in a in a restricted
setting so um this is
uh you know be because if we if we kind
of look at a given entry for that
membership test what we get is the the
sign of SV the I entry of of that of
that Vector times SI J if we're checking
checking for um for for the J column
being being a me for J being a member
then we can push that sign that the the
multiplication inside the sign and then
uh pull out the particular entry for for
k equals J and we get that we're looking
for the at the sign of one plus some
some terms that that are a sum of of IID
um
uh sign R A mocker random vectors okay
so so basically it's just it's analysis
that becomes a question of is that sum
equal to minus one equal to equal to
greater than minus one less than minus
one and it becomes a little bit of a
case analysis in terms of of whether n
is even or odd um but it's not too far
from the analysis as in you know Boolean
function complexity of the um uh of the
majority function and we had a little
bit of hope that more more of that
Boolean function analysis goodness might
enter in here but it doesn't it doesn't
seem to um one one point here is that if
if instead of doing the bundling all at
once and then kind of this offline way
if you if you take a given uh Atomic
Vector bundle with it then take another
one bundle with it take another one
bundle with it so you know iterate in
that fashion and so we have this kind of
nested series of of uh of sign add and
take the sign add and take the sign add
and take the sign looking at just m
equals one looking at just you know one
one number in each case then the the
sort of the signal which is um you know
can can we detect that the first atom
Vector the atomic Vector we started with
can we detect that it's in that bundle
that the signal kind of dies
exponentially fast so the probability
that we'll even be able to tell that
we'll get any difference for that is is
one half it's a coin flip plus one over
two to the r a tiny bias in favor of
being able to tell that X1 is is in that
bundle so so this um you know just as an
observation about the the relative
weakness of map B this was actually
already known to uh Dennis Cleo and and
and co-authors here at the Redwood
Institute
um uh but what they also noticed is that
um if you if you clip not down to one
but if you sort of do something
intermediate between map I and map B and
you you clip to small integers then you
continue to have that kind of Decay but
it it it occurs much less rapidly so you
have a kind of uh moving average which
is which is done in a in a nonlinear way
which is kind of an interesting
interesting construction I I think um
and finally um Bloom filters uh are are
actually an instance of um and which
were sort of defined independently
within the VSA Community um are Bloom
filters can be interpreted as as vsas
where here you you generate um binary
Vector the atomic vectors are binary
vectors that are zeros or ones when you
have some K nonzero entries out of out
of M and um and then the you construct
the sparse binary Matrix with each
column being generated in that fashion
independently so that then a a counting
Bloom filter as it's called would be the
the product of such a a matrix B times
the characteristic Vector um and a bloom
filter would be the the coordinate wise
minimum with one of of of B times V in
that same fashion so you're clipping
clipping down to down to one these these
positive values down to one so this is
this is kind of in the of course in the
in the offline setting and there's a
similar operation in the in the online
setting as you as you would expect for
these and I should counting Bloom also
is is sort of an unstructured version of
the uh of the count Min
sketch now um
it okay um just one last thing here
would be an that that what we have is an
analysis of set intersection for for um
VE for vectors representing two
different sets and um which apparently
has not been done for Bloom filters
which kind of surprises me so if you you
know if you happen to know where
somebody did this um please let me know
but um the the the way in which you can
you can use Bloom filters in in this way
is to first of all have a function which
sort of accounts uh compensates for the
collisions that you will have as you
have more and more members of this set
Rel you know you will have collisions
meaning that you know you'll have a a
nonzero entry in in in this binary
Vector sparse binary Vector a non-zero
entry in this other sparse binary vector
and they're actually at the same
coordinate so they Collide in that sense
and so the the number of nonzeros that
you will get in that b time V will be
smaller than um
um uh than than you know K times the
number of of uh elements in the set that
you're representing and this H function
sort of compens compensates for that and
in an appropriate way for the
expectation and the thing is that the
that the quantity in question is
concentrated enough that you can apply
this H function you know even without
the expectation and still get a get a
quantity that's uh get an estimate
that's uh
appropriate so so we have an analysis
for how big a a you know a bloom filter
has to be in order to rep to support set
intersection
operations um and here we we had to use
a not not Bernstein's inequality not
McD's inequality but a sort of Burnstein
form of McD's inequality in the sense
that
um we needed to be able to have
properties that depended on the on Lo on
the variances of individual random
variables and not on just on bounds on
their their magnitude but it needed to
also take into account um lack of uh
Independence between you know dependence
between different random variables that
we're analyzing so I think uh I will
skip the counting Bloom filters which
has this curious expression analogous to
high school algebra but in terms of
coordinate wise Minima and showing the
coordinate wise Minima can Minima can be
used and um so yeah the there's there's
no particular sense that any any of the
analyses that I've given are tight
um uh and and one problem here is that
sort of for several of these the the
order of operations is is is significant
um and map B is not actually bundling is
not actually ass sociative so so you
know it's kind of difficult to to to
think about well even in that case um
even you know it's difficult even on on
that basis and there is that that sort
of exponentially fast forgetting that
map B has so so all of these things
presumably could be improved in some
fashion um and uh one one key thing here
is not is is a need for for an algorithm
which is a a sort of a natural way to
Define uh binding between two sparse
binary vectors in a way that kind of
preserves the right amount of sparsity
but is but is also analyzable is natural
and so on
so thank you very much for your
[Applause]
attention any questions for
Ken
so um is there a sense of like where all
the different functions or
functionalities these um primitive
operations can have like is there some
categorization of their powers like you
you know you I'm saying consider the
model where you start with these Atomic
vectors and you're only allowed to use
binding rotation and so on right like
what can what can you do with this I'm
I'm I'm not sure of the full extent of
that I and and I guess sort of a
different question would be how to what
extent can can other data structures you
know do the things that that you know
what what's how does this compare to
against the competition for for set
representation and and so on and I don't
I don't have a have a good uh answer for
that but I mean you in principle you can
you know for map ey especially you know
you could keep composing these things
however you know however you wanted and
and you know you you you need to
correspondingly increase the the
sketching Dimension the the size of the
atomic vectors but you know there's I
don't think there's any particular
limitation in in that respect so is is
my understanding correct like it does a
lot of things very like well but oh
sorry it doesn't do anything any
particular thing very well but it does a
lot of things that I I guess you could
put it that way yeah yeah it's not it's
not I I think the the the motivation for
for many people is this sort of biolog
iCal connection or that it's it's it's
not just that that it's a nice data
structure but it's a nice data structure
that a fruit fly uses you know so so
that that's something worth
understanding you know that well you
know I don't know what your attitude to
fruit flies is exactly but I you know
they
so that's
it
any other questions for
Ken let's thank him one last
[Applause]
time